in this video we'll talk about
voltage-gated potassium channels
as the name suggests the conductivity of
these channel is dependent on the
voltage change and these channels would
conduct potassium
when there is a change in voltage in
this video we'll learn the structure of
voltage-gated potassium channel we learn
the gating kinetics we'll also focus on
the function and the classification of
voltage-gated potassium channel so stay
tuned till the end of this video
this is a
overview to the
uh
potassium channel structure
we can see this is the n terminal this
is a c terminal and inside the membrane
we can see there are several
transmembrane alpha helices which which
contains the
voltage sensor domain the fourth helix
is actually the voltage sensor helix
this has a lot of positively charged
residue which is responsible for this
voltage sensing mechanism in between
fifth and the sixth helix there is a p
loop which harbors the selectivity
filter the selectivity filter ensures
that only potassium ion can pass through
this channel and not other cations like
sodium
so let's try to understand and let's
look at the extra crystallographic
structure of a
potassium voltage-gated potassium
channel so this is kind of a cartoon
depicting the crystallographic structure
where we can see the performing domain
selectivity filter and the voltage
sensor domain and voltage sensor domain
as i have mentioned contains several
positively charged residue which is
responsible for the voltage sensing
mechanism
now let's try to understand how the
selectivity filter works
when potassium is present in the
environment it is solvated by
interacting with several
water molecules while it passed through
the pores of the
kv channel it should have similar kind
of interaction and that is provided by
the carbonyl ah
carbonyl oxygens of these voltage
sensitive
residues
so
sodium is a smaller cation and it cannot
have this optimal interaction and that
kind of tells us about the selectivity
of potassium channel and that is why
sodium cannot pass through but potassium
can because all the interactions are
optimal with the carbonyl oxygens
now let's try to understand the
different states of these ion channel
there are two alternative states closed
state
and a open state and the ion channel can
switch between these two alternative
states
notice one thing the voltage sensor is
pushed upwards while in the open state
and that kind of tells us
about the voltage sensitivity of the
potassium channel
so in the open state the pore is open
and
potassium can pass through this pore
now let's try to understand the getting
kinetics by looking at
electrophysiological data so under a
wholesale
wholesale patch clamp configuration we
can clamp the voltage into specific
magnitudes and record the current here
we can hold the voltage at minus 80
millivolt and try to record the current
from across these ion channels what we
found is
the
current is zero
at minus 40 the current is still zero at
zero millivolts there is some amount of
current and the and it increase when we
make the voltage more positive
and this is how we can get the iv
characteristics of voltage-gated
potassium channel
this tells us the current can be
recorded from this ion channel in a
relatively positive membrane voltage
so that kind of
tells us how this particular ion channel
is very selective to a range of voltages
but that is the mechanistic aspect but
how this is reflecting in terms of
physiology in order to understand that
let's try to look at the action
potential again
but before that let us try to understand
what really happens in these voltage
ranges
at minus 80 millivolt
the inside of the membrane is highly
negative so there is a attraction
between the positive charge in the
voltage sensor and the inside of the
membrane that is why the pore is
remained in a closed state
but in a positive membrane voltage such
as 40 millivolt millivolts
the inside of the membrane would be
positive and there would be a net
repulsion between the voltage sensitive
helix and the inner side of the membrane
that would push the helix outwards and
that would lead to a open configuration
of the potassium channel now we
completely understand how voltage
sensitivity is allowing channel opening
or closing now let's try to understand
the action potential
so this is how the molecular events in
action potential look like we are
looking at a small portion of the neural
membrane here there is sodium channel
voltage sensitive sodium channel in the
onset of depolarization voltage
sensitive sodium channel opens and
sodium ion rushes in
that allows the membrane potential to
become positive
and a lot of
membrane potential become positive a lot
of sodium ions get in
now when the membrane potential is
becoming positive let's say at plus 40
millivolt
this membrane this voltage sensitive
potassium channel starts to open
now voltage sensitive potassium channel
allows potassium ion to move out of the
cell
thereby restoring the membrane potential
to a negative value again
now one thing you should note that these
potassium ion channel has a slow
kinetics
so just after the onset of a voltage
change they take some time in order of
millisecond
to conduct the ions and thereby there is
a lag in these ion channel conductance
probably that is why there is a lag in
action potential as well the width of
action potential is roughly about a
millisecond right
okay so this voltage sensitive potassium
channel can modulate inter-spike
interval it can modulate the waveform of
action potential it can modulate input
resistance and it can overall modulate
the excitatory inhibitory balance in a
neuronal circuit so in terms of
physiology modulation of voltage-gated
potassium channel means a lot
now several diseases are associated with
mutations in these kv channels such as
epilepsy
so generally we have normal
uh neuronal activity in the brain but in
epilepsy what happens there is a hyper
excitability which results in the
seizure like symptoms
now there are several mutant mutations
which are reported in these kv channels
namely kv 3.3 where
which are associated with epilepsy we
can understand why this happens
because when we have
when we have
less amount of potassium channel or the
non-functional potassium channel
the
repolarization does not take place
or takes place at a slower pace that
leads to this hyper excitability
that leads us to the therapeutic
importance of voltage-gated potassium
channel modulation so let's say this is
the steady-state firing rate inside our
brain
when there is a change in this firing
rate there could be diseases for example
hyper excitability occurs in epilepsy or
bipolar disorders where there is a
increase in the spike frequencies
also the decrease in spike frequency
occurs in depression or in multiple
sclerosis
so in these circumstances if we use
proper agonist or antagonist of kv
channel it might restore the firing
frequency to a steady state level and it
might regain the function that is why
these
kv channels are really important
modulators and therapeutic targets
now the potassium current which is
recorded from this kv channel has two
components within it
one is a fast activating and fast
inactivating current another is a
delayed rectifier current actually there
are different type of potassium channels
which has these characteristic waveforms
such as shaker and shell which are
mammalian kv-1 and kv-2 family having
have these particular kinetics of fast
activating and fast inactivating that
means their kinetics is relatively fast
they opens quickly and they close
quickly as well
in contrast if we talk about shab or
shaw these names are in drosophila and
which which corresponds to kv-3 or kv-4
family all these channels has a
relatively uh slower kinetics that means
they take more time to close
now we can clearly understand how these
different ion channels can
differentially modulate the action
potential waveform or spike frequency
moreover one important thing that we
should note the distribution of these kv
channels are heterogeneous in different
neurons
especially kv 1.1 is found throughout
the axon whereas kv 2.1 are found in the
proximal dendrite kv 4.2 is found in the
distal dendrite and kv 3.2 is found all
over the dendrites so these differential
distribution of voltage-gated potassium
channel
might imply in terms of their in terms
of the overall neuronal functionality or
signal integration
now let me tell you a cool story about
the discovery of a voltage-gated
potassium channel
scientists were looking at fly mutants
and they have ems treated multiple
mutant lines and their assay was simple
they thought
since these potassium channels are
responsible for modulation of action
potential if there is a mutation in the
potassium channel it would lead to a
hyper excitability normally a fly is
anesthetized under ether exposure
and it doesn't move its legs or any body
parts
but
there are category of mutants which came
out of these screen which shows hyper
excitability and that is why they shake
their legs
even under ether anastasia when they are
not supposed to shake their legs
and these mutants are known as shaker
mutants the name says it all shaker leg
shaking right and that is the discovery
of kv-1 family of
voltage-gated potassium channel very
simple experiment but really elegant
now we understand in retrospect that how
shaker mutation might have affected the
action potential waveform so it might
have prolonged this repolarization phase
and that leads to the hyperexcitability
now apart from voltage gated potassium
channels there are many other type of
potassium channels let me tell you that
there are 32 genes in mammals which
encode for voltage-gated potassium
channels other than voltage-gated
potassium channels there would be two
transmembrane bromine containing inward
rectifier channels four transmembrane
domain containing two poor domain
channels there are slope
slow kinetics potassium channel slopes
or sk type of potassium channels in
different videos we'll talk about the
characteristics of each of these ion
channels but let us summarize what we
have learned so far we learned the
structure of the voltage-gated potassium
channel opening and closing kinetics
distribution of this ion channel and the
functional aspect of kv channels
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up
don't forget to support me on patreon if
you're an indian viewer you can support
me via bmupi your small contribution
means a lot for me and my channel
my detailed lectures are present in
unacademy you can use my code ap 10 to
get a 10 discount and as usual don't
forget to like share and subscribe if
you have a suggestion let me know in the
comments